that are edible?
What if we could completely change the experience,
like you see with that absinthe serving
that is completely 3D printed?
And what if we could begin to put ingredients
and colors and flavors in every taste,
which means not only delicious foods
but the promise of personalized nutrition
around the corner?
And that gets me to one of the biggest deals about 3D printing.
With 3D printing, complexity is free.
The printer doesn't care
if it makes the most rudimentary shape
or the most complex shape,
and that is completely turning design
and manufacturing on its head as we know it.
Many people think that 3D printing will be
the end of manufacturing as we know it.
I think that it's the opportunity to put
tomorrow's technology in the hands of youngsters
that will create endless abundance
of job opportunities,
and with that,
everybody can become an expert maker
and an expert manufacturer.
That will take new tools.
Not everybody knows how to use CAD,
so we're developing haptics,
perceptual devices
that will allow you to touch
and feel your designs
as if you play with digital clay.
When you do things like that,
and we also developed things that take
physical photographs that are instantly printable,
it will make it easier to create content,
but with all of the unimagined,
we will also have the unintended,
like democratized counterfeiting
and ubiquitous illegal possession.
So many people ask me,
will we have a 3D printer in every home?
I think it's the wrong question to ask.
The right question to ask is,
how will 3D printing change my life?
Or, in other words, what room in my house
will 3D printing fit in?
So everything that you see here
has been 3D printed,
including these shoes
at the Amsterdam fashion show.
Now, these are not my grandfather's shoes.
These are shoes that represent
the continuation of his passion
for hyper-local manufacturing.
My grandfather didn't get to see Nike
printing cleats for the recent Super Bowl,
and my father didn't get to see me standing
in my hybridized 3D printed shoes.
He passed away three years ago.
But Chuck Hull, the man that invented it all,
is right here in the house today,
and thanks to him,
I can say, thanks to his invention, I can say
that I am a cobbler too,
and by standing in these shoes
I am honoring my past
while manufacturing the future.
Thank you.
(Applause)